yeah and I worked at a warehouse this
year actually at Target warehouse and I
can attest to that like I do we because
the pay Gap was obviously the Min on the
side where they're moving pallets and
unloading trucks they're making like 24
and then I'm like packing online orders
I'm making t19 but my back was hurting
hips were hurting I'm like I can't do
this long and then men come home and
they're like it's not horrible I'm like
so you're right like a lot of women
don't want to do manual labor I
personally don't want to do manual labor
for too long I will if I have to but I
mean I was willing to make 18 instead of
24 so I wasn't like unloading truck